so I'm just wondering how many of you
guys have ever been pulled over for
speeding sucks doesn't it
no how many times have you heard someone
say that oh if you're a chick you can
get away without getting a speeding
ticket that's bull
and as that scenario usually plays out
it's a little bit something like this
[Music]
hello
each aspects page what's up we got a
problem I just got pulled over what do I
do
oh yeah I pulled over you just need to
be sexy cuz chicks do I never get ticket
never matter it's a statistic I can
Google the statistic for you seriously
just sexy just be sexy negative license
are worst which
where are you going at this hour there
little Missy it doesn't actually matter
where you're going because in this panic
situation you always make up some crazy
excuse as to where you're going to make
it a lot more where you're actually
going well I was alone my my way I got a
phone call and my friend's alpaca farm
was caught on fire so I am going to save
it this bottle of water I have brought
the fire oh really what's it pretty good
excuse they're a little late but you
know how fast you were going well I
don't think I was actually going that
fast I mean it wasn't going too fast
I had just fast enough because I need to
sleep how do you see you trying to
spiritually both of the tragedy was
about son you have a good night have you
ever talked your way out of a speeding
ticket ok maybe not you but what about
someone you know leave a comment or make
a video response with your reenactment
[Music]